science breakthroughs daily from science
mission in nature neuroscience
researchers show that elevated levels of
cyclic adenosine monophosphate that is
cyclic EMP in brain cells had a positive
impact on stress induced behaviors in
mice researchers found that levels of
cyclic MP can be elevated by disrupting
the activation of an enzyme called
phosphodiesterase for or pde4 knocking
out the regulatory protein kinase cdk5
in brain cells disrupted pdu for
function and elevated cyclic EMP levels
this positively affected behavioral
responses of the mice to stress inducing
experiments this study thus demonstrates
that pd four or cdk5 can be the targets
for depression next in normal cells
promoters for various transcription
factor genes remained turned off dot 1l
protein recognizes these promoters for
your interaction with C make p30 complex
and facilitates methylation and
acetylation towers histone h3 leading to
the dissociation of hdac1 and dnmt1 the
upregulation of this EMT regulator by
the complex enhances EMT induced breast
cancer stem cell-like properties leading
to increased tumorigenicity invasion and
metastasis for more news visitors at www
science mission calm or science mission
facebook page thanks for watching